far from the front lines Vladimir
zielinski mounted a one-man offensive on
his Excellency
warning Ukraine's defeat would bring
dire consequences the goal of them
present War
against Ukraine is to tour Our Land
our people our lives our resources into
a weapon against you
19 months into the war Ukraine is at a
Crossroads in dire need of longer range
weapons and military hardware just as
Russia forges new alliances to replenish
its depleted Army the Ukrainian poor
zielinski is not only asking U.N members
for more support he wants countries to
formally stand against Russia when
hatred is weaponized Against One Nation
it never stops there
Each decade
Russia starts a new war in many ways
zelenski is Ukraine's secret weapon an
unlikely leader turned charismatic
diplomat
his first in-person visit to the U.N is
part of a push to convince more Nations
that his fight is also theirs try to
explain to a number of countries who
have been on the fence or who have been
hesitant to back Ukraine why it's so
important what's really going on and why
Ukraine needs and deserves their help
the U.S remains Ukraine's biggest backer
delivering tens of billions of dollars
in military aid just like zelenski
President Joe Biden warned countries
they cannot sit idly by
if we abandon the core principles of the
United States to appease an aggressor
can any member
state in this body feel confident that
they are protected but in Washington
where zelenski will travel Thursday
Republican lawmakers are increasingly
skeptical of the price tag of U.S
support
zielinski elected to congress is he our
president I don't think I have to commit
anything I have questions for him
where's the accountability and the money
we already spent polls show a majority
of Americans are cooling on support for
Ukraine knowing time may not be on his
side zelenski faces added urgency to
find a path to Victory Jackson prosco
Global News Washington